I think my favorite movie that you ever
made beside the whale is School ties and
you know the other guys in the film it
was what Matt Damon Ben Affleck I wasn't
he was in it Chris and boom you go out
to LA and you get this movie School
times what how long did it take you at
first I read for it it was when I first
arrived in town and it was under a
different director
um and uh I didn't get the job and they
were casting for their David for a long
time I'm told and then about eight or
nine months later I came back under a
new casting director and they said okay
um go meet Sherry Lansing who was
running Paramount and she said uh I want
to do a test what are you doing on
Thursday and I thought you know in my
naivete I thought it was like an exam or
something like that I didn't know and
SATs yes exactly if you're panicking a
little bit and then um we went to the
Paramount lot and Tech Fujimoto was the
DP and uh and there's then Matt Damon
was my scene partner and I just remember
thinking he's already got the job and uh
I'm you know this is my shot here and
I'm going okay don't mess this up
um bring things down a size I was used
to being on stage at that point in my
life and playing to the back row and I
knew that I needed to match pitch with
Matt so I I felt like um
I was this wingman or something and I
think that's why I got hired but these
guys that you ended up with that you
know Ben Affleck in this movie uh Matt
Damon Chris O'Donnell
this was before we even knew who Ben
Affleck and Matt Damon were uh this is
right this is before Goodwill Hunting
and then you kind of have described that
even with your acting career
it was those guys you were always up
against it was the same guys trying out
for every part you know and and do you
do you begin to like just get frustrated
by these guys and when you see them hit
it with Goodwill Hunting and you're like
what the [__] happened
for them I like I know these schmoes I
was telling you happy for that you know
right they did a great job and
um and in making School ties in a way
I felt like David because his
his story is that he wants to belong and
we at some point in our lives or another
we've all felt like we've had our nose
pressed up against the glass and there's
some something keeping us out and we
want to be a part of what's in there in
this case David wanted to be a part of
this school he he wanted the camaraderie
he he he wanted the glory that sport
brought him but it came at a cost and
the barrier was is that he was Jewish
and their anti-Semitism kept him out
so for all that need of wanting to
belong I identified with that because I
felt like I want to be a part of this
Hollywood also that scene in that movie
where you're wrestling you know you're
in the shower
you're naked Matt's naked and then you
guys fight in the shower and you're
wrestling were you guys fully nude oh
yeah in that scene you were absolutely
yeah no kidding I would have freaked out
well yeah it was scary it's scary to do
that and when you're an actor and you're
starting off you're ambitious and game
for pretty much anything they say jump
you say how high but right at the same
time I appreciated that this isn't
really for wow we're a scintillating
factor of going hey look at that naked
people the point of it was is that when
Damon's character says what he says
about David it just reveals who he is
his anti-Semitism and his prejudices
stripped down naked and it's ugly and
the door is locked and they fight over
it like shaved Apes that need to be
pulled apart because they've run out of
things to say to one another and it just
turns into an ugly knuckle dusting fit
and that's the point of the scene really
if someone said to me listen this is the
role of a lifetime but you got to fight
nude I'd have to turn down the roll I'm
not confident that area I'm just not I
admire I admire your confidence